[Music]
welcome to ear biscuits I'm Rhett and
I'm link joining us today in our final
recording from VidCon is youtuber
Globetrotter vlogger an adventure seeker
Louie Cole from his channel
fun for Louie Louie travels all over the
world and documents his experiences and
it's probably not an exaggeration to say
he's experienced more things in the past
few weeks than most people experience an
entire lifetime the dude is the
real-life version of the most
interesting man in the world he I think
in his YouTube channel fun for Louie
which hosts daily vlogs are these
travelling adventures currently has 1.5
million subscribers and 155 million
video views some of his escapades
include spearfishing and Australia
swimming with ducks and London yes he
did that integrating himself into the
Himba tribe of South Africa horseback
riding in New Mexico Paris skiing in the
Alps and row boating in Vietnam that's
just a few of his adventures this guy
has a good time and he's not just
experiencing the stuff we wish we could
experience he's the type of guy you'd
want to be experiencing this stuff
alongside he's got positive outlook his
free spirit his ability to live every
moment to the fullest really inspires
his audience to face their fears and
break out of their comfort zones of
course this made us wonder if Louie has
any fears himself hmm so we talked him
about that and a few other things got
some great stories I there's got to be a
sequel with this guy by the end but we
talked about the gang faceoff that
happened on the double-decker bus that
he bought and drove around London we
thought to valorize eating many extreme
dishes on his now private 'add or
deleted I think yeah food for Louie
channel including he ate a live scorpion
and a live tour Angela that gets
controversial and so we unpack all of
that and finally how his itinerant
lifestyle impacts his personal
relationship yeah this is definitely one
of the best one of our all-time favorite
conversations we've had on air biscuits
and we know you're going to enjoy it but
first we want to take a moment to
mention today's sponsor Squarespace
Squarespace is
the easiest way to create a beautiful
website blog or online store for you and
your ideas
Squarespace features an elegant
interface beautiful templates and
incredible 24/7 customer support
try squarespace at squarespace.com and
enter offer code rhett and Link at
checkout to get 10% off offer code rhett
and Link 10% off Squarespace build it
beautiful and now onto the biskits our
lives intersecting with yours is
difficult because there's one huge
variable and that's your life whenever
we get together which this is this I
mean we passed at events but like gotten
together to create something like even
this is like oh this is it immediately
felt feels more special because you're
such a moving target well but it's like
you're the you're the the real-life
example of the most interesting man in
the world that's how I think about it
yeah I see that Dos Equis commercial and
he says all these things and I'm like
but I know a dude who kind of does all
this in it in real life yeah disagree
again I mean there's obviously the the
the behind the scenes it's every second
every day is not as interesting as the
videos and the instagrams but yeah I
guess this has been the most interesting
action-packed kind of W years of my life
this whole YouTube adventure right okay
so let's let's backtrack from this
moment cuz even if I look at your
channel currently it's it's basically
real kind I mean you're you're within a
day you're pretty much loads load
something up every day yeah every day
everything do you ever miss a day I've
started to as of the beginning of this
year I just thought you know it was only
me at set the challenge of doing a daily
vlog and then I just thought it become
it become a little bit unhealthy where I
just thought I'm not taking any me time
I'm not taking any rate I'm um okay but
still give or take I can look at your
chin on and I may take off like one day
a week one day fortnight but it's around
it's it's the least I'm doing at least
six days a week so you got the VidCon
madness begins video which has been up
about a day because that's a you've been
in VidCon about that long yeah
and that's that's almost 15 minutes but
then if I backtrack from there I can
tell okay you came from Hollywood you
were riding on I'm just a just based on
thumbnail only yeah you were inside a
lot from your thumbnails yeah you were
in Hollywood riding horses and then
that's probably Griffith Park yeah and
then you were on the beach doing a
cleanup is this like a self-imposed
cleaning up a section of the beach it
was there was a charity and we were
helping do a beach cleanup with him yeah
okay and then you were doing a GoPro
audio test under water that was in New
York you were in New York for that yeah
doing some rooftop instagrams
testing out some of Casey's danger toys
whatever that means
it sounds off he's got these wheels
these electric you know these you've
seen those toys with the wheels and
Evan's floating around on them yeah yeah
yeah they can be dangerous and your mom
was in New York yep I can tell that and
then you were doing some skateboarding
but in Central Park I'm like yeah I'm
like hitching a ride on the back of one
of those bicycle taxis you know those
there dies that cycle around and but but
he didn't they didn't know you were
doing it not to begin with we made
friends we made friends quite quickly he
was cool so even before you were in New
York where were you swimming with swans
oh that was in London in London yeah and
then do we I jumped in there's a lake in
Hyde Park and I went swimming in it
there's actually like your article
swimming and that's not a thing and make
England usually like these are this is a
lake full of ducks and so just look at
the lake yeah but you're allowed to swim
yeah it's like a thing like I didn't
notice a thing so no yeah we were anyway
that was that thumbnail we were jumping
in swimming with this one's flowing
around us but put three videos before
that the first video in your London
series is called back in London so right
before that when you were talking with
animals where were you that's Italy
yeah it's alia you were in Italy and and
this is over the and I'm just I've just
taken you through the car is through
just five weeks Italy London New York
Los Angeles and then where you going
after VidCon I am doing a road trip up
to
Portland and then on the 11th of August
I'm going to Sierra Leone in West Africa
where the where the Ebola outbreak
started but I'm going with the UN and
World Vision this charity I'm going to
go and I know World Vision interview
some some patients that have recovered
and it's gonna be I mean it's gonna be
pretty intense to UM that trip so what
we're gonna get into like specific
places and like highlights but let's
just talk about workflow like what's
your approach I said you know you walked
in here you had your camera you're kind
of leading with the camera and so what's
your general approach like shooting
editing all of that what you work for I
mean oh just shoot as much as possible
during the day I've just found I'm happy
to go through a bit more footage each
day to capture those moments and I'd
rather capture a little bit too much I
think that's my what I figured out over
the years are doing this VidCon is an
interesting one because a lot of its
relational so a lot of its just meeting
people chatting with people all day and
that's a little bit more difficult to
capture those moments you want to share
because some of the conversations it'd
be weird if I was like like this the
whole time with my camera so the to be
honest VidCon is an interesting one that
you can capture bit the party scenes I
would go and chill in the hot tub a
little bit when I'm on the move and
there's a bit more activity to the day
and we're moving around a bit and
there's a bit you know that's it's a
slightly different workflow because I'm
I'm explaining a bit to camera how am I
feeling about where I am I might I might
get put the camera on someone else and
ask them something and then it's just a
montage of clips of what we're up to and
then you know another chat to camera and
so it's pretty it's pretty edit heavy
then if you yeah so a lot of it I mean
we had a panel this morning I was with
Casey Neistat and Ben brown and the Dean
and we all do well min Casey and Ben do
daily vlogs and the Dean does travel
vlogging and we we were saying it's it's
almost entirely in the Edit you know
obviously you need to capture the
moments but then it's how you cut that
together and that usually happens for me
late at night I'm my problem is I've got
that FOMO thing where I can't miss out
so I couldn't like pull myself away
from a party to go and edit I have to
wait till everyone's gone to bed yeah
which at things like this I mean I
couldn't even edit last night we had
this amazing conversation with a few of
us about how we can change the world
together as youtubers and you know
having an impact until 5:00 in the
morning and then I was like who is in
this brunch Jerome Jarre do you know
Jerome Jarre he's the biggest Viner in
the world and you know he's that French
guy tall French guy he does so really
funny okay okay anyway his whole thing
is making people happy maybe making
people smile and challenging people to
face their fears so he like does like
public singing and he goes up to people
in public and like I guess pushes him
out that comfort zone
anyway we had this I mean I going to now
but we had this incredible conversation
about well just give us the conclusion
what's the answer how are we changing
the world when we were in bed at 5:00
a.m. I want to be a part of this okay so
my original point is I haven't even
edited yesterday's video yet so it chops
and changes when when I edit and their
work flow could depending on what I'm
doing so I don't want it to take over
especially conversations like this which
I'll explain the crux of the
conversation was society's broken we
have got this incredible voice with
millions of ears potentially between the
network of people I was looking around
last night at the YouTube party and I
was like I mean this group of you know
the small group of people here we could
100% change the world you don't need the
politicians and the and the big
corporates to do it like we we could do
it and then we had this conversation of
what is it that's broken and how do you
mend it and it was all around the
subject of compassion and I think the
three words which my friend Dave who I'm
doing a lot of called charity ideas at
the moment and these are his three words
are compassionate problem solvers so
finding compassionate problem solvers
and getting them to release that and
other people when I mean there's I mean
this was a [ __ ] like we start the
conversation at 9:30 and ended at 5:00
a.m. so I'm struggling to summarize it
but it was like it was documented I mean
the cameras are rolling
so I filmed a bit and then I just put my
audio on record I just wanted to listen
back because it was just very exciting
because there's a lot of amazing people
and minds here and it
people had incredible incredibly
different experiences people from all
over the world but the one thing common
is somehow we've built this incredible
platform that people seem interested in
our lives and what we're up to and
there's this potential to inspire people
and make a difference and I don't know
that's that's where my head's at at the
moment yeah let's skip from workflow to
kind of what you want to accomplish you
know your environment is always changing
you're always figuring out how to take
the footage that you capture which is
always compelling but it's but it's a
testimony to your editing and all this
the music and the style that you bring
to it but it's all for a reason
like I really get a sense that you you
want to elicit something from your
audience what it what is that
what is your goal it's an interesting
journey I think I started off just
wanting to document my life and at times
I'm just doing what I want to be doing
regardless and then it just happens to
be oh I'll just film with this whilst
I'm doing it other times and what I can
fall into and I want to avoid is
suddenly thinking oh I need to make sure
I'm making an interesting video today so
then I'll deliberately choose to do
things to make them interesting and I
don't think that's bad in itself because
it does motivate you to you know have a
fun day in not just sitting all day but
I don't want that to be the primary
drive for me it's like I have to make
interesting videos that wasn't ever the
goal it was just to share my life I
think my my goal and what I would love
to do is to inspire people when they
watch my videos a lot of people say oh
you've really helped me face my fears or
dream bigger or you know some of it's
about travel and that's my like face the
fears of jumping off of random rocks or
or even that's the interesting thing a
lot of my videos are literal fears like
you know jumping out of a plane and
going to crazy countries but I think
just if you just think about fear in
general that's the thing that holds
people back in life whether it's a fear
of jumping up playing or whether it's a
fear of leaving your house or me making
new friends and if you say to you know
if you're if you explain to people it
embrace this this you're pushing out
your comfort zone and and
and even if it's scary doing it a lot of
people have said you know I wouldn't
have even come to VidCon but you know
you're watching your videos of you know
helps me overcome that and a girl
yesterday said she wanted to go to
she'd never left her state and she
wanted to go to university in New York
and she's like plucked up the courage
and she's now got place and she's going
from California to New York in a month's
time and she said it's all from this
this general feeling of like facing your
fears which I guess people feel inspired
to do so I think this whole thing is
like you can watch my life and see what
I'm up to and there's this shallow
sometimes level of like just pleasure
seeking fun and jumping off things I'm
having you know in here and they're
riding horses I'm jumping in lakes but I
hope my hope is it's a lot deeper than
that people can see that my kind of
heart behind it all is embrace life and
and be passionate about what you do and
hopefully that can inspire others to to
do it in their way it might not be
travel it might be something DIF what
cuz you know there's an interesting
there's an interesting dynamic when you
when you watch what you do I mean one
thing is you might be tempted to think
that you don't have any fears you're
fearless that guy's fearless I'm scared
everything but that guy's fearless and
then the second thing might be like man
I can't go to all those places how am I
gonna have how can I embrace life and
get the most out of life when it's going
to the cubicle every day or you know
whatever situation somebody might be at
the classroom yeah yeah that is a tough
that is a tough one
I know I think that's why I if I choose
to vlog daily it means those off days
where I'm not going out having
adventures and I might just be sitting
at home in my family and the most
adventurous thing I do is walk down to a
coffee shop and get a coffee which often
happens it shows that life isn't this
adrenaline 100% every day doing the
biggest and best thing it's there's
there's a reality to it as well and I
think that's why I quite like the daily
thing right but what are your fears you
know in this big conversation we had
last night I realized where sometimes I
do think I'm fearless
I realized I realize I need to think
about that because I think there's some
fears I have which are normal which
aren't a normal classic fear
well let's let
let's start just but what sometimes it
is like that okay I think I'm think I've
got a fear of missing out that foam a
thing but I think that goes bigger than
just like the party I think I think
that's it recently been you know I'm in
this incredible position and I don't
want to miss out on the opportunities
that I can have and then it's like well
what are the opportunities the reality
is in my position with I mean brands are
contacting me every day saying we want
to work with you in a new projects I
could easily draw that and kind of get
absorbed into the world of like just
making as much money as possible from
this platform which it's a tough one
because yes some I've monetize my videos
and I'm earning an income and I've got
dreams that require money so I for
instance one of them is I want to buy a
big plot of forest and build a tree
house Ewok village in it and live there
because I haven't got a house at the
moment I was like who wants a normal
house I want to live in an Ewok village
yes we have been locally build a guest
room
we'd be yeah I mean I want to be
multiple but we went and looked at a
plot of land up in Santa Cruz which was
like I mean it was a big plot of land
but it was like half a million dollars
and I was like yeah but but anyway my
point is I can work with brands if they
work organically with my channel and my
viewers are cool with that and
understand the principle of me doing
sponsor videos and it can work or I can
get I'm like well I just do sponsor
videos every day you know and then I'm
just so that's one of my fears is I
don't want to become unauthentic and I
don't a lien oh my audience and I don't
want to kind of sell out to things I
don't believe in but I also don't want
to be on my high horse to be like I'm
not gonna I'm you know I'm just gonna
make money yeah I'm not gonna make money
because the reality is though money
isn't it shouldn't shouldn't be a
motivation but I think it's a brilliant
tool and thing that kind of quit that
can really free you to do you think
awesome things so no that's been playing
up I mean this is the most honest I've
been Oh Noli and I hope this isn't like
Oh crazy subject to talk about but know
this whole thing's a fear of mine I
don't know
what to do in this situation I don't
know whether to embrace it and just do
it all or whether to like step back a
bit I'm scared of missing opportunities
and I'm scared of what if I if I get if
I do the wrong thing what could happen
well the Ewok village is a definite yes
yes the brand would pay you with an Ewok
village and take money out of the
equation right would that simplify
things yeah absolutely yeah
well I think that money represents an
Ewok it's an equation yeah but seriously
seriously I mean just one piece of
advice I would give just hearing that is
I think that the nature of your content
and the nature of you think the things
that you that you're doing is that there
is a really you're concerned about
authenticity and that's a great instinct
and you should keep that instinct it's I
think there is a really authentic way to
incorporate brands that you believe in
into the kinds of things that you're
doing because there's you know I mean
whether it was like you know Red Bull is
an example of somebody does all kinds of
adventure things which there's like a
connection there but just simple things
like if there's something that you use
or something that you could help you do
the things that you do while you're
traveling like there's a million people
out there we would want to give you
something like that to talk about you
know as a sponsor you have to figure how
to navigate it but it's like there's a
lot of opportunity there and I don't
think that if you if you maintain that
authenticity you're not gonna alienate
people I would think and then we could
build that ye walk village yeah we'll
help you will come and we'll stay oh
yeah come stay we next protocol should
be in yes that's right you know and it's
not our job to solve your fears neither
it isn't I think it's our job to just
make you talk about them no no I I mean
my yeah I just need I need some
processing time with as many sponsors as
we work with though we we are like oh
you definitely should be we can find a
way we can talk about that more later I
would I will say that I think that the
the challenge is to find integrations
that the brand already reflects your
your values yeah because a lot of brands
want that's a good point
a lot of van brands want to attach the
selves to us to you in order to by
association
put your values on to them you know yeah
and that's what you that's what you
don't want to do you know and that's
where it when you when they throw a
dollar amount out there sometimes it's
difficult for us say okay oh now that
there's that amount of money on the
table well we got it now we got it come
on boys we got to have a conversation
right because there are different kinds
of realize you can't do that it can't be
about the dollar amount right because
they're different kind of brands I mean
coke could come to you and say we want
to sponsor you and at that point it'd be
like okay why is Louis being sponsored
by this huge soft drink but there are
smaller and their slogan is is has been
enjoy happiness see how that really
makes sense but what does that work for
you and you don't answer that yeah
there's not two specifics but the
general the general thing is I I mean
it's been tough some some brand things
have worked with it starts off great
you're like yeah I think we're on the
same page by the time this contract sign
and you're starting to you know you
starting to get things reviewed then
suddenly everything changes and you're
like wow this wasn't over the plan like
and then it's yeah this stress of like I
really don't want to start like do it
reading lines and skies in my this isn't
a fictional thing this is my life so
this this is that this is the struggle
anyway but yeah I mean I think it is but
I think we are getting to a place where
there's enough that's starting to work
correctly that there's hope that it can
be there can be trust the brain can
actually trust us yeah but but let's
just see if that happens yeah the other
fear of missing out is an interesting
one because that's just more we're going
just more inside your head and not
inside your wallet right yeah yeah this
is like I think the other thing is like
I don't know if it's quite related but
like is this whole shiny thing syndrome
where I'm like I arrived at something
like VidCon and I'm like I know like a
kid in the candy store I'm like huh and
it's all about a lot is relational I
need only go and check to that person
look at this person and also people come
up to me they're like Louie we want to
talk to you I'm like yeah let's talk and
then it's this whole thing of and then
it's like meeting my viewers and it's
like exciting but also sometimes about
overwhelming and and it's this whole
thing of I my attention is not in one
place for like more than 30 seconds and
this is this is Rick probably here
sitting down and having a conversation
because you you're scared of missing out
because why you know is there so what I
think part of its just wanting to make
the most of everything you know and make
the most of life and I mean this is
great I haven't really I don't know I
don't I don't know if there is the
answer but yeah let's talk about it I
mean let's see if we can derive it
because now I have a theory that as a
youngster you were locked in a dungeon
and deprived of all sorts of stimulation
so now you're just a young boy at like
age 18 so let's see if we can get there
oh yeah how did you how did you become
Louie I mean how did you become this guy
that is the most interesting man in the
world for real no I mean brilliant
family really close with my family
loving home I was always a brilliant and
not like like extremely smart but like
just like like in the British Way of
brilliance like when Charlie says lovely
he doesn't mean lovely he just means
great I mean great yeah right got it
great family so is Martita
yeah and we're British quite um quite a
typical like grew up in the suburbs
middle-class didn't have loads of money
my dad's been a high school teacher his
whole life he's actually been I think
like 33 years teaching at the same
school and we've always lived in the
same house so this is a very you know in
terms of like in terms of security it's
just been same house same town I grew up
in it's been nice it's been great but
also this has been running strand of
like my parents have been quite
supportive and encourage all of us to
think outside the box I've got two
sisters as well so it's like thinking
outside of the box and as the kids are
but I was like I love rainforests I love
jungles I'm obsessed with like jungles
so they let me completely transfer all
my bedroom into a rain forest I had like
a running waterfall I lived in a cave I
painted trees all over the walls I had a
pet iguana roaming free in my raising as
long as he didn't leave the threshold of
your door then yeah and after airing
yeah I mean where did that idea come
from I know my head I mean I just always
loved I was always in as a kid I was
always in another world like I was in
Fantasyland the whole time like I just
daydream the way my way through my
childhood I was just always playing
games even at school I imagined I was it
I was a spy in a military camp like
every day I was like I just create this
fantasy world around me - it wasn't an
escapism I just saw one I loved seeing
the magic in the world around me yeah it
was fun it just hit me that rainforest
cafe could be a sponsor ya know I love
this I've always liked your room but
they serve food yeah isn't great though
but you know but it know your financier
is like that was that is my room my room
was like the rainforest company but and
then it's been I guess just crazy ideas
I've had that don't fit into the normal
like so let's fast forward ten years
like I bought a double-decker bus like
there you know the London double-decker
buses got quite a fast-forward I bought
a bus got some friends to paint graffiti
all over the outside and then I used to
run and help with young people and like
bad neighborhoods around London like
gangs and we and they set up a music
studio in there and we like I used to
like help with youth clubs and churches
and different people did you drop out of
high school no no no this is that I'm
fast-forwarding past high school
no I I did I didn't go to university
though that's the interesting thing and
a lot of my friends I've talked to that
doing bigger things you know
entrepreneurs and they set up big world
potentially world impacting things
didn't do degrees I didn't go to
university which is a common thread with
a lot of my friends at home but your
parents kind of stoked that flame of
always you do this yeah it was in it and
then do it
yeah invent whatever you want to do do
it yeah
so what was was the double-decker bus
the first example of that
how many is multiple like I remember
wanting to do something really fun for
my 21st birthday and we could try and
rewind I'm trying to think what else
so my jungle bedroom teenage years I did
a I did a I did like a work placement
instead of University and then where was
that would you work
I did like 3d animation I worked in an
office in for Sky TV oh really so it's
all like because I love graphics and
visual stuff was that before or after
you were homeless for the first time
this was before okay so anyway then I
left then I left the corporate world of
like I mean it was fun and it was visual
it was graphics but it's still at office
and I had to keep not keep almost a
cubicle like it was an office I just had
the same see every day but then I
thought oh you know and this isn't me I
can't do this anymore
so after two years there I just left I
thought I can I can save some money
because at that point you like what's
important to me I'm paying rent and it
mayn't it made me challenge everything I
knew about society I was like wait hang
on I don't I don't think this has to be
the way that I'm told it is like I think
I can just decide what I believe so the
belief that I needed a house because I
was like that's a big out going you know
renting us a house so I just bought a
minivan and I just thought I can just
live in here and it's free so I let in
your giant said well my they was
supported they were like they were like
well we know you're skilled enough to go
back into a workplace if you want to but
in the meantime go and have fun and you
know that I've got a funny story so he
went lived in this minivan for a few
years drove around Europe with my
friends literally survived on maybe 20
dollars a week always like eating cans
of food and I just thought oh I can live
for free who needs money and it was this
whole thing of like I just want to might
at that point I was like time is so much
more valuable and I remember leaving my
job and thinking with all the time in
the world I can do anything I can
I can literally take over the world not
in there in a good way yeah in a good
way I can just do anything and I still
gotta put gas in that minivan
yeah and that's because I was always
traveling with friends I would be I'd
literally put in a gas station and be
like can everyone just donate put in
like $1.00 I mean I'm talking American
so you feels like
can everyone give me one pound to put in
for fuel so I had to get one to chip in
with bit 10 pounds in the tank it was
literally like that I remember often
running out and and often having nothing
and going hungry but I love this testing
the limits of what do I need and how can
I adapt to create more time in my life
so is this whole experiment of time then
I got I had this vision for the
double-decker bus I told everyone I'm
gonna get double-decker bus but I you
know you need you need 10,000 pounds or
whatever to 18,000 dollars even to
dealer and then someone came up to me
and they said we love your vision here's
the money which was awesome
I think someone came up to you well I I
was I was involved with circles of
people that like want to do cool things
right so someone showed their friend he
showed their friend and that I found
this almost like a foundation that when
I support cool projects and they said we
love the idea here's the money and it
was like literally wrote me a check
now is there a belief system that your
parents kind of put in place that kind
of kind of formed the structure for this
was it just your parents saying go off
and have fun or you know was there
something else well I mean I won't go
super into this but like my and on a
personal level I have like a kind of a
faith like I grew up in church and like
okay I think part of that mentality of
seeing a bigger picture to the world
it's not just the here and now it's like
there's more going on and I think that's
all always thought this sense of magic
there's a spiritual realm there's more
going on and I later on read books like
the secret where you like you know
you're like putting things out there and
you know when you or it's like having
even if you don't want to put it in
terms of God and stuff like if you have
a belief in belief that you can do
something and that something's going to
happen I honestly feel that you can make
things can happen you know like you can
almost will things to happen whatever
whether you believe that's like a
spiritual spiritual yeah whether you
believe that's like a spiritual like
God's got a path and he's you know doing
something or whether there's just a lot
of universe well whether it's a law of
the universe well however you perceive
it because I'm honest like preaching my
personal beliefs but like how have you
but I know that you gave there
Jesus shout out in your draw my life
well I just said you were inspired well
I just wonder yeah I mean I just wanted
to explain I wanted to mention it
because for me personally that is a
massive impact on my drive and
motivation what's difficult in in
society is there's a lot of connotations
and and and assumptions when you label
yourself if I lay with myself a
Christian for instance it's you just you
know it's just like such a negative
thing I'm a get a lot of stuff and also
there's like the whole Republican
Christian southern inner southern
American thing state you know everything
all of that for me I I like the idea of
you know Jesus was an incredible
character whether you believe he was a
son of God or whether you believe he's
just this cool guy that did some awesome
stuff or whatever like so when I say I'm
inspired by Jesus and I want to follow
what how he taught to live I don't I
feel like that can't be that offensive
for people I think he did drive a
double-decker bus yeah but you've got
the bus so it got the bus yeah let's go
back to the bus so we've got the bus and
from this motivation of like honest you
know growing up being taught as a kid
it's bigger than you it's look at the
world around you we've care for people
love people this is the whole message I
grew up with like it's about loving
people and then I'm like well what was
in the mini van like driving around I'd
meet these kids on the street which had
nothing hadn't didn't have good homes
some of them had left you know run away
from home or whatever I remember
sleeping under like in a highway like a
noise you know there like a highway the
bridges that go over the highways and
there's a little tucked in there I
remember this kid was like destroy it
run away from home for some reason the
police were after him and I tell her I
found him anyway and it's conversation
with him and ended up having a
conversation on the phone with the
parole officer his police person that
was gonna look out for him and and just
I just thought wow this people really
like in much more way more broken
situations in their life and they're
like struggling and I just thought like
I can help like I try and help and love
them in some way and then I just thought
this idea of oh if they had a place to
come that wasn't like this set location
like run like government run youth
which there's so many restrictions and
paperwork and I just thought oh I've got
some friends around me as well that love
to help and I just wanted to set up and
I thought oh I could live in the
double-decker bus as well because it's
much more spacious than the minivan so
in the van where you can make a
double-decker bus work double-decker bus
had some it kicked kitted it out I mean
I need to show some pictures in a minute
these guys can't see but anyway so I
just thought it'd be great had to have a
safe space that I could pull up in the
neighborhood kids could jump on boards
it was all safe like we had often
volunteers I even worked alongside the
police the police said at one point this
is the best thing we've ever seen like
this project so it was like working
alongside people already in the areas
like charities churches the police the
council and just helping support young
people often through just having
somewhere to sit down have a drink have
a like a hot drink of hot chocolate or
something or play a computer game or one
and rookie they want to record like we
were like making CDs of their music at
the time and so that was my motivation
was this how can I love people in an
interesting way that's not you know
doesn't fit into the norms of society
necessarily but it's like how did the
bus work like it was okay I'm gonna
drive up under this bridge and say hey
guys I got a double-decker bus come on
get in I had this sound system that was
so loud cuz I also used I forgot I used
to DJ a little bit as well just at
parties for fun so I had this sound
system was so loud the the base speakers
could set off car alarms as we drive
past so you could drive down the road
and like all the cars inside the road
the car loans ago so you just start
pumping music and people would come
flooding and then I had a microphone and
I just hand it took it I was like do you
like rap um CD and I just give him
microphone and then suddenly they're
spontaneous MC battle on the street it
would happen all the time and then and
then I found on dust around London yeah
and I I don't I don't see myself as a
like an entrepreneur but I I soon found
a way to fund it all by kids saying can
I rent this for my birthday party and I
was like well yes you can so on the we
did like a clown that did you know on
the weekends I used to drive around kids
for their birthday parties and teenagers
and just to rent the bus out and that
used to cut that used to fund the whole
project
it was brilliant and they would and I
even got a
on my Facebook and it said five years
ago this is like bit last week five
years ago you drove me around in your
bus for my birthday party it was the
best night of my life and I was like wow
okay it's so but that didn't last
forever we like to take a quick moment
to break in and mention our sponsor who
helped make today's episode possible
Squarespace yeah building a website can
be tough and even if you do know your
way around coding creating something
that looks good and works well is a time
consuming affair whether it's for a
business site a portfolio a restaurant
or whatever else in this day and age you
need a website and lucky for you and a
Squarespace makes it easy to build
beautiful websites they provide simple
powerful and beautiful websites look
professionally designed regardless of
your skill level now we've had a number
of versions of rhettandlink.com/store
the sleekest and coolest one yet really
guys it's sleek and cool go check it out
rhettandlink.com/store 7 online support
and a beautiful website for only 8 bucks
a month you can even get a free domain
if you by Squarespace for a year so
start a trial with no credit card
required and start building your website
today
and make sure to use an offer code rhett
and Link to get 10% off your first
purchase and to show your support for
ear biscuits and thanks to Squarespace
for showing their support of ear
biscuits by being a sponsor Squarespace
build it beautiful this episode is also
brought to you by Sevilla Sevilla is the
naturally sweetened soda with no sugar
no calories and it's also non-gmo
project verified
ZV is available in 15 delicious flavors
including cream soda
black cherry cola ginger ale and even a
tonic water and a whole lot more all
with zero calories it sounds like you
might need a savior right now cuz is
there something here huh yeah let me get
my Ziva now we got a case and we put
them in the fridge here the office and
they were gone by the next day I didn't
even get to try all the flavors but I
did try grape which is my current
frontrunner I tried I tried cream soda
I enjoyed it that's as far as I got and
everybody else drank them all I think
we're gonna have to stock our secret
fridge in our office and we can get
and you should stock up on some Ziva for
your secret fridge to go to cbn.com
slash podcast because they're giving
away thousands of free six-packs now
that's not a six-pack for your your
belly that is an actual six-pack of Ziva
which because there's zero calories
could help you in your quest to have an
actual six-pack who doesn't like the
sound of coming home to a surprise soda
on your doorstep head over to Z Viacom /
podcasts to get yours that's Z via zev I
a.com slash podcast now on to the
biscuit so you were here you were doing
the double-decker bus thing and then Mia
how did that come to an end so it was it
was pretty full on its most evenings a
week and then every weekend was busy for
me doing that I struggled to delegate
and build a team around me so I was the
driver always I never I sometimes took
someone to help me with security because
then I mean the stories I could tell you
about the craziness that with working
with urban like bad neighborhood young
people tell us one I mean okay what's
the craziest word I mean there's one so
it's similar to American the gang
problem in London isn't as severe and
there's not guns so that helps but they
they still there's still this liked her
gangs don't have guns either I mean yeah
they make some of them do but not like
no not everyone not everyone's carrying
a gun okay but they can get hold of guns
illegally so anyway so I II was working
I was living in South London a time and
I had worked in this neighborhood where
there's this particular gang and I'd
built relationships with a lot of the
members and was just trying to be a
positive influence in their life but
it's I mean it's a crazy structure like
the drug dealing there the the hierarchy
everything so I took a bunch of them out
for there one of those one of their
birthdays I was like oh I'll take you
I'll just take you out so it wasn't like
they weren't renting it I was just like
come on let's go and do something free
before they hang free before the game
anyway so we go off into um
double-decker bus we'll go up into
London pumping music some of them are
like emceeing often when I stop the bus
people crowd around and then other
people
wanna join in so often it will be
there'll be spontaneous MC battles with
people on the street that just happen to
be walking past and it attracts people
over so anyway there's like this other
gang that kind of show up and they start
like emceeing and then they have their
own double-decker bus now they just walk
along the street and then and then and
somehow they ended up in the bus no no
and on the same day
probably this no this is the thing
that's two decks they original they did
separate the original gang members were
chillin upstairs I'm like either they're
probably playing on the PlayStation
whatever this other gang no there's a
PlayStation yeah thanks 52-inch plasma
screen anyway so downstairs this other
gang come in and they start like chat
like emceeing on the mic and then they
start representing their ends which is
like their neighborhood and they start
shouting out because this is turf war
right they're like North London North
London I'm like like because my gang is
from South London like anyway I'm like
I'm just gonna I'm just gonna I pulled
over I was gonna go upstairs and check
that this is this is safe like that cuz
I can't kick them off I can come down
like walked upstairs the gang I'd
originally came in I had pulled over
balaclavas on their face five of them
blacked out all black balaclavas black
masks I don't know England come
balaclavas so it's just there I host the
mouth where you're gonna do a robbery or
something right and and they pulled out
like knives I'm like I'm like whoa I'm
glad you went upstairs guys guys chill
chill like this isn't this is not
happening you are not having a gang
fight in my bus like and I because I
built relationships I'm eight they
actually respects me so I'm like like
potatoes my stuff
calm down I can tell these other guys to
like get off like this fine you know we
don't need to start a fight over this
but what was crazy is they ended up
making friends they came down it was all
chilled and I was trying to be like let
you don't fight you because you live in
a different area this makes no sense
I think in the gangs thing maybe like
this drug territory where they this deal
is stuff anyway I managed to like an
ecosystem of yeah I noticed I managed to
somehow make this bond over the music
name everybody's people on a
double-decker bus once you get on the
same
and also because we're driving around
we're driving in and out of different
areas and there's no we're not in like
oh you're in my location you're you're
confusing him they're going in their
territory then they're going in somebody
else's territory this is like the most
genius gang solution there's ever been
so I mean I wrap them all off at the
police I've had to like I've had to like
confiscate weapons off got it guys I've
had to like Brighton physically break up
fights it's been it was a crazy time
actually I mean I should probably write
some of these stories down but but it
sounds like logistically it started to
become too much to manage yeah and I
think it was just yeah it was tiring I
felt like I'd I was achieving the bigger
thing I'd wanted to and then what
happened was the the YouTube stuff
started alongside this right so I with
some friends started eating crazy things
just as a it was just it was never my
thing it was just like a silly thing I
did it was this whole thing of like
questioning society why can't I eat a
spider let's face my fears you know and
so the first thing you ate was a what I
actually drank it but on my on my food
for Louie channel which is the first
channel I had a new tube it was we had
some old footage on a mobile phone of me
like eating a little spider off the
floor and it was just just to be just it
was nap it was never meant for YouTube
it was just me messing around with some
friends and they'd be like eat that
spider today right so I'm like okay okay
cuz I'd already at that stage already
like done jungle trekking and traveling
in like I'd seen like there's this why
not I can eat spider and and anyway so I
did that and then you you had seen
people he despite her probably yeah
exactly so then I did that and then I so
we had a few clips that we put on
YouTube because we just let all this
what do we make the thickness of thing
and then my friends were egging me on
and they were like they encouraged me
and then I drank a whole bottle of
wasabi sauce and then things started
getting more like your dream this was mm
and maybe 2011 okay maybe maybe end of
2010 there yeah so you have this this
footage off of youtube you start the
channel
you can call it food for Louie because
hey you already had some meeting stuff
yeah and then they just keep leaving you
more stuff it kind of escalated
alongside the stuff so I was only doing
snowboard I mean it was like yeah it's
like once once a week and I'd be doing
my bus thing still a week and then once
a week go around my friend's house what
am I gonna eat this week
oh we bought you a box of crickets so
you can eat them all or you know and
then it's just escalate and people were
suggesting things in the comments that's
when the video started going viral a
little bit and then that's when we
realized we're like huh this is this
could be a thing like people like this
these people like this and also at this
point a few other UK youtubers reached
out to me because I was starting to get
some traction and interest and these are
the like the younger guys that were
coming up so this is whole crew in
England and it was just the perfect
timing and they wouldn't to make friends
of me and I was like huh so what do you
do what do you eat I don't know I did
and they were like oh no no we did you
know we vlog in our bedroom and I was
like I didn't even know there was people
on YouTube I just watched music videos
on there or like cat videos so all like
fail compilations uh-huh
so I'm like okay so you're tracking in
your bedroom what do you eat yeah so
you're checking your bedroom and you're
not eating the mattress or dropping out
of the window you're just talking yeah
just tool kit I'm very interesting so
check to these guys and that's when I
came to I think at this point it might
be in 2012 I came to a VidCon anyway
that's food for Louie and met a bunch of
the American youtubers and I was like
this is an amazing community and at this
stage I got in a ton of trouble in the
UK for what I was eating I actually got
threatened with the rest taken to court
for eating a goldfish which anything
England is actually illegal so the RSPCA
showed up my house they always had it
was it was live in swimming it was
swimming around I picked out a bowl
chopped it up quickly and in my opinion
still didn't cause it to stress off or
like pain like unnecessary pain you
didn't wallow it live you know its head
off so then you swallow yeah then I ate
oh so in my favor my thing was if you're
gonna eat me don't be naive and think
that that animals not dying
for you to eat that right so my I took
it to the extreme of like well I didn't
like the fact that I'm killing this
animal that's not what I'm finding
pleasure in it was just pushing the
limits of like how can I challenge
myself to think outside the box and eat
something crazy and it turned out I
ended up eating live animals like
scorpions and spiders and that's what I
think a lot of the variability of the
videos is like okay people thought I was
a psychopath right well okay so let's
let's explore a few of these because
that was our that was our faction yeah
was I think the tarantula one was the
first one and I was couldn't start
watching is about all of them tell us
about the tarantula that was the the
most scary woman the most scared it's
time in my life because this tarantula
was this was when when we bought it from
the pet shop right they they wouldn't
handle it they were like you can't
handle this species of spider these it
was like some Brazilian I can't exactly
owes anyway so they kind of like kind of
put you know two of them are like
standing back pushing it into this
plastic case I walked home with it did a
bit of research like a trench was
dangerous and it was mainly like you
know they're not fate it hasn't got
fatal poison but it were it's gonna hurt
a lot if it bites you and especially
around your mouth throat area like I'm
like the swelling yeah they can see
there being a serious danger here also
it has these hairs all over it that can
like flick it flicks a predator tires
far away as far predators to to deter
them right something can all of this
some like mmm yeah this is scary and
what was the biggest most ambitious
thing you had done up to that date I'd
eaten the scorpion already which was
again scary because of this stinger and
the pincers and it grabbed my mouth
started on the crickets right like live
crickets and I'd as a kid I'm pretty
sure I've eaten or I mean I'm sure I'm
sure I'd like eaten live crickets and
things in the garden or whatever like
yeah sure like I I do everyone's eaten
number a spider during their sleep this
scorpion was what what type of scorpion
emperor scorpion is the biggest species
of scorpion
had a stinger so I upgraded from I think
I'd done I might done cockroaches before
that which were pretty vile like the
taste of pretty boy but the the the
scorpion was the first kind of arachnid
predatorial little thing that I'd eaten
where I was like this is going to attack
me rather than just yummy when in a
video you hold it by its tail's you have
a stinger and then begin to drop it down
and you're right on my tongue to the
pincers grab your tongue then you just
kind of like bring it right in and just
yeah yeah I mean that was scary but as
soon as I had the stinger because this
thing is the dangerous part right so you
ate everything up into the stinger pop
that out put it on the plate the great
thing of these videos I mean I'll
fast-forward to why I moved away from
this and then I've actually now taken
these videos down right I'll explain in
a minute but they it was all my friends
were crowded behind the camera laughing
and egging you know but there's a lot of
banter they were like saying funny
things that was hard part of the fun of
it it wasn't
do you know Bear Grylls he does like the
man vs. wild yeah so the whole time I'm
like this is no different from going out
into the jungle pulling over a tree
stump and finding a spider and then you
know eating it which he does all the
time cigarette everyone's like wow like
he's showing us how to survive well Bear
Grylls jumped off a cliff would you he
did way in my opinion way more extreme
things than I did but kind of got away
with it as like oh he's out in the wild
right I'm like oh I'm just in my friends
living room like you've got a pair
sitting on the couch yet but it's the
same thing it's just it's a weird out of
context right so the Scorpion a called
tranch allure next step up because now I
can't hold the sting of the tarantula
right it's got to its massive fangs like
inch-long fangs just a question about
the Scorpion if it's got venom that can
come out of the stinger
when you eat it isn't that venom no it's
all in the thing it's all anus so also
there's a difference between being
injected into your skin like a venom and
poison it's different so you can some
venom like once you digest it it breaks
down it's like protein whatever like
okay so I did enough research to be like
I'm pretty sure this isn't gonna poison
me it's not a poison it's just you know
it's just if it stings you that's like
you know like bee stings are acidic or
whatever it injected this
said engine I'm pretty sure your stomach
can cope without if I ate a bee I don't
think that would hurt either like it's
longer than sting me on the way down but
you had to find this out there's only so
much we can wiki yeah I know and we I
mean we really didn't do much research
either and the part that was part of the
fear you did say pretty sure pretty sure
wasn't well we had this whole joke
there's a guy in the show I mean no
doctor oh you can move an admit but he
wasn't a doctor he was my friend and we
called him the doctor the doctor and we
were like is this cool and he's like
yeah is this how like very like blase
like yeah yeah like it was we made the
whole joke of it
he actually when these videos taco Varro
his his employer asked him to not be on
the videos anymore
asked him to step away because they
didn't feel it was they he was
representing the company you know he
asked they asked him to stop be
appearing on them so at one boyd
replaced him with a dog my friends pet
dog here is just like they're in it in
the same jacket just looking like it's
the same thing okay so now read ascribe
the tarantula so the trench ler it's got
these poisonous Barb's or whatever and
it's got these fangs and I'm like oh if
I don't eat this correctly it will bite
me because they're ferocious and it's a
very vicious kind of attack thing that
you shouldn't handle it I looked online
I researched eating tarantulas I found
these Amazonian kids they would pull
these trench hoes out the holes in the
ground and and the way that they the way
they grabbed them I was like ah okay
this is how you've always wondered why
you grabbed it I was like how did he
figure this out so these kids like what
they do is they pin it down say put a
finger on it back and they they pull its
legs up so it all this legs are above it
yeah so it can't run away and it can't
grab it
and then you just pick the legs up and
they all like you know bent backwards
you know all the legs are pointing
toward the palm of your hand and you're
holding an end holding it and then it's
almost like a lollipop it's like the
legs of the you know and then it's the
body and you're underside we understood
the trenches but then that it's exactly
like a lollipop it's a spider lollipop
but the the fangs are still there and I
was like if I I need to also I don't
like the idea of causing unnecessary
pain and I eat meat right so in my head
I'm like right I eat me I never research
how that makes being killed the reality
is and
but and the sad reality is for all of us
we eat me we don't research where it's
come from it's come from slaughterhouse
it's come from you know battery chickens
where they don't get looked after
they're in agony their whole lives often
so I've got a lot of criticism for my
channel by the way like people hated it
and not yeah some people loved it some
people hate it was very controversial
but my thing wasn't like I'm gonna
torture this spider I'm gonna pull its
legs off one by one
and then you know you know I just was
like my thing was I'm just gonna eat as
fast as well so I don't I put through
unnecessary pain so within seconds my
ideas within seconds on it to be dead
right and also you're explaining this on
camera yeah some of it yes I mean I'm
like I don't want to also don't to get
bittered so I'm like if I just bite his
head off
Oh quick oh you know so I'm like ha
bricks hovering a photo in mouth this is
where I like I honestly black out I
can't remember happened next
and I can watch it on video but I
blacked out from the fear because I'm
like if I don't really like miss if I
miss my mouth or something and then it
sinks its fangs into my lip like that's
what I'm scared of like I got a spider
bite my mouth like imagine like and then
their barbs I'm like this could go all
like my face my whole face could swell
up so I'm these reality real things I
could happen right but I just went for
hours you know you know shaking my
friend who was filming was the one of
them guys were back of the room shaky
like even right now if you talk about it
again I'm like kind of backing away from
you so do a bit the head off all done
really scary but yeah done no not really
I think you got to get it down then you
got to actually chew it to assume it at
that point what's this dead no no no
it's not gonna bite me I'm chewing
that's fine that's just because once
that because did you also do research or
at least ask the dog that if it was okay
then once you bite the head off not only
can it not bite you but it can't like
fire its barbs because I would be afraid
about the barbs coming out off of the
legs as it was trying to get down my
throat only she didn't research it I
just assumed what's good at my mouth
those things spike spiky things wouldn't
be as bad but I were there no I it was
all right it was actually okay what was
the texture like like a legs were saying
the legs were quite chewy the the bulb
the the bit of the back like the
I don't know what that is that yeah the
spider but was it was squidgy and like
goopy it had like it was like creamy
inside its fight or do some soda and
what was the taste it was like mushrooms
and I can't read it explain the taste it
wasn't you a blackout yeah exactly
anyway let's not look let's not spend
too much longer on it but the fact is I
did all these things I got in a lot of
trouble because you know I know what is
gonna say is the RSPCA which is the
Royal Society of prevention against
cruelty to animals it showed up at my
house it came here with freak with
lights yeah I don't know how they found
my house with an F literally an FBI
style file on me like literally show me
flick through documentation every and
every video like you know and their
point was they were like we were against
what you do and you're taking it too far
and they were waiting to pin something
on me see we're waiting to pin something
on you yes so they wait it's been
something on me they said this goldfish
thing right
they're like this is in the UK illegal
now what I could have done is say I
didn't film it in the UK filmed in
France or something you know because I
was traveling at the time of doing
different things with friends but I was
like something in me was like no I'm
just gonna be honest like I I did feel
this I don't think there's a problem
with it
right and if if I'm gonna get in trouble
like I found that a bit ridiculous like
you can go fishing in the UK you can
catch you can just shove a hook through
a fish's mouth pull out the water slap
you know stab it in the head hmm
take it home cook it in eat it I'm like
stabbing it in the head with a knife and
and chew and chomp it and bite his head
off with my teeth can I can I catch a
fish in the river with a hook take it
out and then bite its head off and then
take home and cook it in here you know
yeah this is my home and this is my
whole theory right so I'm like wide
pulling out and buying his head off and
then eating it how is that illegal I
don't understand anyway they took me to
court they took me to court and it was
in all the tabloids all the newspapers
national press it was like psycho guy
you know eats that I was like hammered
by the press about it and no one was on
my side because it's not like I'm
standing for an important issue yeah
yeah yeah it's just like a wit like
who's this weird guy and he's eating
goldfish this is this is wrong England's
big on animal Cory but so am i I don't
wanna
cause animals pains but but then I'm
like I also I am also a meteor and I
know I animals are dying for me to eat
this is my point this is my hole the
premises like are you making this point
from the witness stand
yeah I'm not talking to the judge and he
thinks it's ridiculous but they're
spending the the charity of spending and
the honestly he thinks their case is
ridiculous
yeah the RSPCA have is the biggest
charity in the UK to have the most
donations millions of people donate
their private money to them they spent
families have really good commercials
they spent fouls well it's good we see
Soros Peas in the kittens and like poor
puppy you know Erin McLaughlin is
singing we more than any human charity
right which I find a bit crazy like I
love animals but there's people dying as
well yeah anyway so they're spending
thousands of people's donations money on
lawyers to pin me down for this and I'm
like really like really anyway so it got
to the point where I was asking my
friends I don't know what to do hire a
lawyer yeah I've had to pay a lawyer I
got to the point where I was like I
don't need to fight this battle I don't
this isn't my I never set out to be an
advocate for like the right to eat
goldfish so I just I just said
out-of-court settlement was like I'm
sorry
I'm not gonna do it again right they
gave me an RSPCA caution it wasn't a
criminal thing just a caution so like
for instance if I if I then a court
again like abusing a pet then I actually
get issued this warrant thing saying I
can't own a pet and then the police can
confiscate me or whatever so I was like
that was that was the thing I had to
admit that I was wrong and there was no
criminal thing filed or anything and I
was like she didn't have to delete the
videos no I didn't have to and they said
like making a public apology and I think
maybe I tweeted something but it was at
this point they were like no I did I had
did have to delete the goldfish one okay
no but at this point some animal rights
activist group to gun in line and they
had gone on to my channel and just
started flagging all the video so like
eight of my videos got taken down the
day after all the tabloids showed me
online
so like ton of people side my channel
actually got removed by YouTube because
so many people flagging it I went back
to YouTube and I was like hey look I
don't agree with this I don't think it's
all wrong
some of it was me drinking bottles of
wasabi sauce you know maybe the goldfish
was too far but that's an opinion thing
anyway
it got my ton of what Pitt back up like
snuck a couple of videos back on it the
same videos they got removed you know
and it was it all started going again
and I was like I think I did a few more
videos after that but at that point I
was like and I think one of my friends
said to me is this what you want to be
remembered for is this your legacy in
life is this channel and right now oh
really isn't I'm not a psychopath I'm
not a life people like you ever like you
definitely about but I'm not and I just
thought this is it was just a weird
thing I was doing that kind of got way
out of control but but the positives are
that I'd met this YouTube community I'd
realize there's a bunch of different
content online and I just thought I can
do anything I want so I at that stage
time I said why don't you film your life
and just what you get up to everyday in
adventures stop eating crazy things and
then that sort it's started doing at the
end of 2012 maybe and it wasn't a
guarantee that it was gonna work
my love worked I think it I think I just
I started a brand new channel didn't
even really push people over from I I
think it scratch yeah I probably had
400,000 subscribers and food for Louie
and I just from scratch started again
didn't even really push my subscriber
base over because those people didn't
care about me they were like that's that
weird guy eating weird stuff they
weren't like how we love you Lilly right
so then I start from scratch got my
YouTube buddies that I knew in the
community to help me and just built the
channel from scratch again started the
daily videos took my double-decker bus
on a tour around the UK and at this
stage this is where the transition was
going back to the start then I was like
okay I'm gonna I'm gonna take a pause on
the bus stuff they're working with gangs
and all that go on a little tour and
then go and spend some time in LA came
out here beginning end of 2012 I think
and then it just all took off from there
met cool people start having cool
adventures documenting it all and now
I'm here with much much bigger channel I
surpassed my channel quite quickly and
now I'm occasionally recognized as food
for Louie but now I've really have like
re rebranded redefined Who I am online
and it's a bit of a mad story of how I
got here really right well in at this
point with it being
you know you said okay you when you
started with the double-decker bus you
took it on a tour but at this point it's
just one adventure after another is what
it seems like
and is it now the adventures are for the
purpose of the exhibition right there
there so people can see it so now it's
just now is it is it like I've got to
plan the next adventure because I'm
gonna continue to bring people along for
the ride is that sort of how it works
well yeah this is the interesting thing
so now I'm like I can fall into this
trap of like I need to keep having
adventures so people keep watching or I
can be like look people were invested in
me whether I'm jumping off cliffs or you
know you know doing adventurous things
or just being me so I really want to be
doing the things that I care about and
want to do and the world-changing
projects and and then I think I will
naturally just be doing that in an
adventurous way anyway and let me let's
qualify the the word adventurous here
because okay what what's the new
equivalent to eating the scorpion in a
trailer because what's the craziest
thing that you've done in your in your
fun for Louis adventures well this is
quite have qualified that this the
connection here would goes back to what
we said before is it's about facing
fears right mmm so that was all about me
facing fears every time I had a new
challenge it was like can I do this
sometimes there's a fear of it's gonna
bite my mouth or sometimes it's a fear
of like this is gonna taste there's
gonna be the worst tasting thing I've
ever aired and now in in my traveling
and adventures it's not I mean what's
rivaled that like it
what has ride with that I mean there's
been some kind of adrenaline style
things sporty things that have been
scary like you know jumping waves on
this motorboat on this like high-powered
engine boat in South Africa and there's
like sharks in the water and there's
like crazy high waves and I didn't have
a life jacket on I remember that's
really the most scared I've been on an
activity thing but I think sometimes
it's yeah I mean I don't know it comes
back to what are my fears right now I
think sometimes the things I'm doing
aren't necessarily my greatest fears but
they are things that people typically
can be scared of right so going to new
places connecting with people or making
friends just doing things day-to-day
that's slightly typically slightly
outside people's comfort zone so
hopefully being like you know I can do
this guys and also show it showing that
it's not as scary as they think so a lot
of fear is in our mind it's not things
aren't black and white this is a scary
thing you should be afraid of I mean
there's some basics human fears which
are good but a lot of it is just in your
mind like and if I can show people just
this is eat you can do this like it's
easy to do this it can encourage people
to do what what do you think it's what's
one of the coolest things you've done
like this stands out in your mind like
you can't go back there in your own
memory whether Yury watch the video or
not like this was a surreal moment maybe
it's this sunrise at this place maybe
it's it's not jumping the wave with the
sharks yeah the craziest thing the
coolest thing the coolest thing I can
think of this year was I went to I've
got a pilot friend and we ended up
flying this to see are playing around
Namibia in South West Africa and we went
to this tribe called the Himba tribe and
they were like this the most primitive
people group I've ever met they they
pretty much naked they wear like clay in
their hair and they they live in mud
huts right and they speak this tribal
language and they're just very it's just
so basic and they just heard goats
that's their thing
and when you showed up what were they
thinking well there's a good there was a
guide who who translate a bit he grew up
in the area but then had modernized his
lifestyle right so he grew up in a
similar as a kid in in super rural
primitive then modernized gone to a
school and like start wearing clothes
and learn a bit he brought you back so
he came back with us and this particular
tribe had said look we're happy for
tourists to come and it's funny because
they don't they didn't even have a
concept of money they just said bring us
food so you bring up a big bag of like
and you give it to me here's the maze
can we just come and have a look around
it felt interesting because some of the
people there wasn't a bunch of tourists
there but at one point this German guy
showed up with a camera and just no real
interaction with them just taking photos
right and I'm like I don't know I feel
about this like it's it's tough isn't it
because it's amazing to us and we want
to capture it and be like look at these
people like but you'd also don't want it
to feel like a zoo like there yeah you
know so I really wanted him to interact
or to engage and don't speak the
language but I was trying to have fun
and they were showing me how to milk the
goats the kids are loving it I actually
ended up showing them an iPad I had my
bag with a photo booth with the thing
that squashes your face yeah and this
photo actually this photo went viral on
the internet recently as the best photo
and the Internet and I'm one of you or
of love these kids holding this iPad and
all grinning and going crazy so this day
was incredible for me and I want it to I
want it to stay down I was like can we
stay for a few days I want to like live
like them I want to learn how so they we
went we went for a few hours and we went
back that night and they showed us how
they cooked their food and I was like
helping them cook their food and making
a big mess of it and they they were just
so happy so content had no material
possessions apart from a couple of them
who actually had like Nokia 3310 phones
they didn't know how to text they just
used them and they used to charge him
down the road at a solar power solar
panel but they had nothing out in their
clothes but like a mobile phone around
the neck where do you put that all right
they hung it around there yeah hang
around the neck which is a kind of wild
thing so that I think that stands out
was like it's totally fun culture these
people are content they they're not in
the rat race they're not don't care
the crazy thing is then there's the
full-option around them with other
villages to modernize and they just
don't want it they're like no we love
our we love our like traditions and you
cannot like they're oblivious to it and
they see the iPad and they like cool and
they like go and play with their goats
is work like generally it's not a thing
like they don't want to be and what I
loved is they didn't seem to want to
chase after this these technical know
these technology and this other stuff
they didn't have the fear of missing out
yeah I guess they just were so consumed
so content and I mean it was a
mine's by this girl who was obviously
thirsty running around with this little
cut up and she just grabbed a guy and
just milked the goat into tattoos tiny
like fight and go into a couple is just
chilling like just want a cup of milk
yeah cool got really eat yeah I was just
like she's just got everything she needs
you know now you had the option to stay
there
you had the inclination to spend more
time with him but you did do it you
could have I could have there I could
have they specifically at the time that
got the men of the village were off
herding some goats in another place and
they said it might not be appropriate to
stay just with all the women and
children but I would have if the men
have been there and it was cool I would
have changed plans and I would have
slept there I would have liked I don't I
do so in fascinating by this culture I
was like this ie I'm willing to do this
you know this is I'd love to learn and
and also interact and have fun um it's
not about like oh look at these weird
people take photos and leave like I'm
like this you know I know they always
show me how to make fire and everything
it was brilliant I loved it
so that anyway I'm babbling but that's
what that's what it with the coolest
time of my vlogs pretty cool okay so in
speaking of women you just said you're a
being with women in a village this kind
of thing living this life yeah this has
got to this has got to get the ladies a
little excited what the audience being
the most interesting man in the world
this is sexy you know and I'm gonna go
out on a limb here I'm gonna tell you
something my wife has a little bit of a
crush on you and here's why okay she
likes guys with dreads she likes tall
guys I'm a tall guy but I don't have
dreads and I remember the first time we
we saw your your videos and then you
were gonna be it I was like this is I
guarantee this is the kind of guy that
my wife would you have a crush on so you
showed the videos you like served when
I'm latter know me and the boys were
watching some of the crazy that my kids
just absolutely loved the the food for
Louie videos yeah and you know in it
wasn't like she saw it sought it out but
I was like this is you'd like this guy
right they disguise your type in shyla
this she was like
[Laughter]
yeah so but I'm not threatened I'm gonna
happy marriage 14 years and getting
going in the same county as you most of
it hey my what exactly you're constantly
traveling the world so she's this is the
thing this is the thing girls I think my
experiences and some of the comments
from viewers and what it's taught that
the start is like most meridians pulled
in we're like teenagers right because
they're not my friends had their teenage
daughter you right so and I'm a I'm old
enough that they're not is a bit weird
I'm a little bit out too old for them to
have a real like obsession crush on like
some of these young superstar youtubers
that like you know the Justin Bieber
style like right so a lot of the
interaction is you're cool and you're
like an older brother kind of vibe I'm
like I love that vibe like you know I
can I can inspire you guys I can try and
be a good role model
that's much better so I'm not getting
that the same obsession but then I do
meet a lot of people were little bit
older that alike yeah they might have
they might and vines what I II have
gathered is the my lifestyle is very
like a romantic idea I just I don't I
just travel the world have fun exactly
but the reality is there's no security
in that I don't know what I'm doing day
to day often I'm completely erratic
there's not much structure that when you
start breaking it down and start
thinking about not many people want to
live how I do and it sounds romantic so
I you live the best life and wish I
could live like you I don't think
everyone's built for it I honestly don't
I think a lot of people need like a bit
of a bit of like that they want the home
they want somewhere they can just you
know I'm home you know they want that
that comfort I'm built different and why
differently I don't need that and I I
think when people might initially be
finally sigh they suddenly concepts
romantic but the amount of people that
step in and be like oh yeah I want to do
that everything and really when they
think through it I'm gonna write I'm
gonna move out and what has it happened
though have you had we have you been in
relationships that were stressed because
of your lifestyle before YouTube yeah I
was always I always loved traveling and
I I didn't see eye to eye with one of my
ex-girlfriends and she was like she's I
don't like Whitney travel and I was like
but I love
and I was like come with me and then she
didn't wanna and I was just like like
this isn't he was gone
yeah it just didn't work so what about
now what's your love life like I don't
talk about that
but let's talk about more vaguely like I
I think it was even vague thing is if I
was to I just you know a lot of viewers
speculate I hang out a lot of cool girls
on my channel right and everyone's
always speculating who am I in a
romantic thing with ie at this stage I
don't want to like talk about that but
all I will say is like I think at the
moment of my life the only way a
relationship with any sort could work as
if I was traveling more often with
someone that they had a more nematic
approach to life I would never be a fan
of like like a long-distance thing where
I had to go back to somewhere to see
that person so I think that's always
been the thing I thought I thought well
I've adopted a lifestyle which creates
me it means that meeting someone and
being able to start and sustain a
relationship is really hard really time
like I'm sitting the bar really high
like I'm saying I don't live anywhere I
travel the world and I fill my life
every second of every day like it's all
it's quite lot to you know suddenly if
someone's like you know oh I want to be
with you I mean there's a lot that comes
with that there's a lot of yeah
conditions you know and also then I'm
like you know how far if I just fell
head-over-heels in love with someone
what would I sacrifice because the
reality is and I've seen it around like
daily vlogging isn't great isn't always
conducive with like a healthy
relationship that where you've gotten
where you've got like a marriage and you
start thinking about family and stuff
someone some people have done it those
channels with you know there's there's
families that do it but I don't know I
don't know that's all future stuff I
don't need to think through but it's
it's much it the whole thing works a lot
easier with this concept if I'm just me
I'm Louie I'm single and I'm just doing
my thing and I don't need to I don't
need to worry about like someone else's
decisions in it oh well I think it's
gonna be it you know my prediction is
there would be a magical moment at some
point in the future you'll be you know
somewhere in a savanna like riding on
the back of a lion
and you'll come up on this beautiful
beautiful woman like drinking directly
from you know zebra to Buffalo yeah and
oh yeah let's just say a zebra drinking
directly from a zebra and you'll lock
eyes I'm gonna be like well I'm riding
puss in the lion like yeah and then
should be like I'll get on that line
with you yeah you don't have to find
under the zebra would either way yeah
it's it you're gonna be going the same
direction and you know in better yet
she's gonna already be vlogging it you
know she'll be down there next to the
zebra teat with a camera on herself and
you'll be like you understand me let's
make this happen so ladies if you're out
there and you're currently suckling
zebra I'm filming it then we've got the
man for you ladies like there's multiple
yeah all of their heads popped up and
this has been fun man I think this this
may be one of my favourite biscuits ever
made we need to plan an adventure
together is what we need to do is so up
for that our adventurers have to be very
well planned in advance hmm but I didn't
even tell you about this you may have
seen the email but I met a guy yet last
night you may have seen that weird email
that came in from Australia this guy was
like an adventure planner dude in
Australia for years and I was telling
about one of our dreams is to do some
off-roading and surfing combo thing and
like Australia he was like oh I know all
the people to hook you up with don't be
talking about in front of Louie no but
he's okay we'll invite him yeah still
here yes okay yeah all right thanks for
hanging out man this is great really fun
all right
[Music]
and there you have it our conversation
with Louie we had a lot of fun with
Louie I was gonna make a play on his
channel name which is fun for Louie we
didn't have fun for him we had fun with
him in the conversation let him know
what you think about tweeting at him his
handle is fun for Louie use hashtag ear
biscuits I'll tweet it that guy it is
definitely difficult to have a
conversation with a guy like this and
not think man I need to get out more
which i think is you know a good thing
it's a good thing because we should get
out more we should I'm not necessarily
saying that we should be eating any live
stuff or we should necessarily be buying
double-decker buses even though all that
success that's exciting what he does
neither of those anymore in fairness bro
but this whole idea of squeezing all of
the excitement and experience out of
life in as many places as you can that's
something that I'm gonna try to make
happen just in my commute well yeah
that's a Southern California area that's
what I'm good that's exactly what I was
gonna say was it's not like you've got
to like dive in to the Amazon to
experience life I think the challenge
for us is within the parameters of the
life that that is ours that we have you
know with our wives with our kids with
our friends with our co-workers within
the context of commuting finding a way
to squeeze their the realness out of it
learn that moment yeah and there is
something that we can both begin doing
right now that doesn't require travel we
could grow dreads I just started could
you tell no you didn't wash your hair
today I did but I just started I didn't
wash it right right now again okay so
that's it
we're not washed dreads we're not gonna
well it's it's a complicated process
just wiki it man okay it involves
washing and not washing it's you can't
just put shampoo normal shampoo and put
your hands in there separate your hairs
cuz then you can't make dredge you have
to let them lock up and then once they
lock there is a way to wash them but
it's not a traditional way and but we're
not gonna talk about that because that's
gonna be wiki that that's also your
assignment start growing your dreads and
experience life to the fullest those
things are you don't have to do both you
can choose one of the other but they are
mutually exclusive and we'll talk at you
next week guys
[Music]
[Music]